Superman: You're letting him kill
Martha.
Batman: Why did you say that name?
Lois: It's his mother's name.
Jim Kakalios What are the odds of two men at random,
both having mothers name, Martha?
Hi, I'm Jim Kakalios.
I'm a Physics Professor at
the University of Minnesota,
and the author of The
Physics of Superheroes.
Today, we're going to look at the physics
behind some DC Universe films.
Must not have been too deep.
Wow, that would be, like, about 11 meters,
you know, 30 to 40 feet up.
I did a little bit of research.
It turns out that there's a whole sport
that is high diving into shallow pools.
[laughing] And the world record is, like,
11.5 meters
that someone jumped and fell into a pool
that had only 30 centimeters,
about a foot of water.
If you just drop an object from,
say, 11, 12 meters,
and ask how fast is it going
when it reaches the bottom,
if you would neglect air resistance,
it's going about 44 meters per second,
maybe 80, 90 miles per hour.
But if you come in horizontal,
you're maximizing air resistance.
And so you're converting your
gravitational potential
energy into kinetic energy,
but some of that energy goes into work,
pushing the air out of the way,
because you have a large surface area.
And so the amount of
energy available to you
as kinetic energy is reduced.
So your velocity is reduced.
A parachute travels much faster
when it's tied up in the backpack
than when it's spread out.
When the parachute is spread out,
it falls much slower than in the backpack.
So, similarly, the Joker comes down
the way these extreme
jumpers do, horizontally,
to maximize his air drag
and decrease his speed.
So instead of 44 meters per second,
let's say he's coming in
at 20 meters per second.
Let's say it's about 45 miles per hour.
The force is still quite high.
It's about over 3,000 pounds to stop him
in the space of about 1 meter,
once he hits the water.
But there, again, if he
could stretch out the time
by spreading out that force over
as much of a large area as possible,
the pressure is reduced.
In fact, the world record for highest jump
into shallowest water,
11.52 meters height
into 30 centimeters of water,
was by Darren Taylor.
Joker may have actually beaten that,
but I give the Joker an eight out of 10,
'cause I wanna stay on Mr. J's good side.
[crashing]
Let's ignore issues like air drag
[laughing] and his source of energy,
that he would need to eat constantly
in order to have enough
caloric energy to run so fast.
In the human brain,
processes happen faster
than we tend to experience them here.
But no signal gets sent
from neuron to neuron
at a speed that's roughly
faster than a millisecond,
a thousandth of a second.
The blink of an eye is 100 milliseconds.
So that's still very fast,
compared to the processes
on the timescales that we live.
Let's assume that the Flash
is running at a stride
that he covers a meter,
3.3 feet, in a millisecond.
So that's 1,000 meters per second.
1,000 meters per second
is 2,250 miles per hour,
which turns out to be almost exactly
three times the speed of sound.
So he could travel at Mach 3.
He can't actually run
on a vertical surface,
because in order to run,
we require friction.
You push backwards with your foot,
and the ground, because
forces come in pairs,
the ground pushes back on
you and propels you forward.
But that frictional force
requires there to be
some weight on the surface
that you're pressing down.
If the wall is completely vertical,
then no part of his weight
is pressing against the wall.
Maybe his first step
presses against the wall,
but then it no longer does.
If he's traveling at 2,250 miles per hour,
you can ask how fast does he fall
due to gravity in that timescale,
and in about a millisecond
he's only fallen
about 10 to the -6 meters,
which is about the width
of a red blood cell.
So he could appear to be
running across the wall
and not fall down because
the effect of gravity,
like, the amount that he
falls is imperceptible.
But, again, if he's trying to go faster
than the human mind can respond,
then this is why, if he
doesn't look where he's going,
he's gonna trip.
We speedsters have to stick together,
and he gets an eight out of 10.
Superman: Martha.
Batman: Why did you say that name?
Lois: It's his mother's name!
Jim: What are the odds
of two men at random
both having mothers named Martha?
This movie that came out
just a few years ago,
and each of them is in their 30s.
Then their parents were
born in the '50s or '60s.
How common was the name Martha back then?
In the United States, at least.
Not that common. [laughs]
Martha in the 1950s was only
the 49th most popular female name.
In the 1960s it was the 94th
most popular female name.
Now, of course, these characters' names
were set in the comic books
that go back to the '40s and the '50s.
In the 1930s, Martha was
the 24th most popular name
in America for women.
So the question is, how do we
calculate this probability?
If the case is given
Bruce has a mother named Martha,
what is the probability that Clark
has a mother named Martha?
Well, then the probability
Bruce has a mother
named Martha is 1, because
we're specifying it.
So it's just multiplied by the probability
that Clark has a mother named Martha.
So that way, if it's in the 1960s,
the odds of this happening are only 0.2%.
If you just say Bruce and Clark
are two random individuals,
what is the probability that they each
have a mother named Martha?
The probability goes way down.
Think about a dice.
You have six sides to a dice.
What's the probability
that you roll a one?
One out of six, 16%.
What's the probability
that you roll two ones?
Snake eyes, with two die.
Well, you need one-sixth on one
times one-sixth on the other.
It's one outcome out of
36 possible outcomes,
or 2.7%.
So it's much less likely if you're saying
two random individuals,
what's the probability
that their mothers are both named Martha?
If they were born in the 1930s,
it's 0.005%.
If it's in the 1960s,
it's 0.0004%.
Let's assume that they're
using the names in this movie
that were set in the comics
that were coming back in the 1930s.
Then they'd get a little bit
of a boost in probability,
but not much. Still very unlikely.
I would have to give this
no better than a two out of 10.
[orchestral music]
Wonder Woman, I'm not gonna complain
about issues of her strength
or speed and reflexes.
We're gonna grant the character a one-time
miracle exemption from the laws of nature.
In the comics, it was said
that Wonder Woman's bracelet
was made of Amazonian metal,
which is why she was able
to deflect the bullets.
We can actually figure out
how strong the bracelet would have to be.
We look at the momentum
of a bullet coming in.
Bullet has a weight of maybe 20 grams,
but it's going 1,000 feet per second,
approximately, let's say.
Deflects back, so it has a
momentum in and a momentum out.
So there's a change in momentum
of twice the initial momentum.
To change the momentum requires a force
applied for a given time.
If we say the time of the
ricochet is a millisecond,
a thousandth of a second,
then the force the bracelet has to supply
is about 2,700 pounds.
Quite high. The surface area is very low.
So the pressure that the
bullet exerts on the bracelet:
70,000 pounds per square inch.
What kind of metal can handle that?
Pretty much all of them.
Cold rolled steel, stainless steel.
They're all strong enough to
support a compressive pressure
of 70,000, 75,000 pounds per square inch.
I'm not gonna argue with her strength,
but the bracelet itself, I
give this a 10 out of 10.
Lucius: It's called memory
cloth. Notice anything?
Jim: If you're gonna dress up like Dracula
to beat up criminals,
you gotta have a cape.
Lucius: Regularly flexible.
But put a current through it...
molecules realign; becomes rigid.
Jim: Shape-memory fabrics.
Then becomes rigid;
you can use it for hang gliding.
Those things actually exist.
We're used to phase transitions,
where, say, ice melts; becomes water.
Or water boils; goes from the liquid
to the vapor phase, become steam.
But there are other types
of phase transitions
that we've discovered
where materials go from
one crystal structure
to a different crystal structure.
And that's pretty much a
one-way transformation.
Some materials can have a
reversible transformation.
You can undo it by warming
or some other process.
It used to be that the
shape-memory materials were metals
for the most part, like nitinol,
which is used in eyeglass frames.
Presumably, Wayne Technology
has developed a fabric
that, via the application
of an electric field
of maybe some electric
current passing through it,
undergoes this phase transition
and undergoes this change.
There is the Wearable Technology Lab
at the University of Minnesota,
where they're developing
materials that compress
under the application,
say, of a temperature,
that are being used to develop
new suits for astronauts.
Since it's Batman, I
give it eight out of 10.
[screaming]
I was gonna say, that's
gonna leave a mark.
Jon Osterman is accidentally
locked into a chamber
that removes his intrinsic field.
In the comics, it is explained
that the intrinsic fields
are all the fundamental
forces except gravity.
Well, the fundamental forces
of nature, there are four,
gravity, and then
there's electromagnetism,
the strong nuclear force, which
holds the nucleus together,
and the weak nuclear force
is responsible for some
radioactive decays.
Without electromagnetism,
there's nothing to hold
the atoms together.
Without the strong force,
there's nothing to hold
the nuclei together.
And so he would be actually taken apart
at the very subatomic level.
Once he is reborn as Doctor Manhattan,
he seems to have independent control
of his quantum mechanical wave function.
So, quantum mechanics says that
every object can be described
by a mathematical function
called the wave function
that contains all the
information about the object.
If he is able to access
his total wave function,
it has the entire history
of the object that's contained in it,
which is why he experiences time
as backwards and forwards as well.
If you can control over
your wave function,
there's a phenomenon called
quantum mechanical tunneling
that would enable you
to go from one position
to another instantaneously.
So presumably that's what he's
doing when he's teleporting.
And from the "wave" in
the term "wave function,"
there is a wave aspect to nature,
which enables certain phenomena
like diffraction patterns.
You send light through a grating,
and you see a series of spots
due to the fact that the
light has interference
through the multiple slits.
You send an electron through a grating,
and it shows the same type
of interference pattern,
even though it's a particle.
And that's because the
wave function interacts
with the slits the same way light does.
Doctor Manhattan presumably
is diffracting himself.
And that's why we see multiple
versions of him in the clip.
So I'll give him an eight out of 10.
[rousing orchestral music]
Superman changing the flow of time.
He does this in the comics all the time,
like, traveling faster,
so fast that he breaks the "time barrier."
Well, how fast is he going here?
We can figure that out
by looking at the distance he travels
and how long it takes him.
And the ratio of those two is his speed.
We know the radius of the Earth.
It's a bit over 6,300 kilometers,
so we can conclude that
the radius of his orbit
is a bit over 10,000 kilometers.
All right, so the distance he goes
in one orbit is 2 pi R.
So it's 60,000 kilometers in one orbit.
How long does that take?
Well, we can count how long it takes him
to make, say, 10 orbits.
And we can conclude that his speed
is about 400 to 500
million meters per second.
The speed of light is 300
So he's going much faster
than the speed of light.
So he gets points for
indeed violating physics
[laughing] and doing that.
Of course, he loses points,
because if you're going that fast,
I don't know how you're
constantly changing direction.
Because in order to change direction,
you need some other force
to be able to pull you in
towards the center of your circular orbit.
So he loses points for that.
So I would say, overall, five out of 10.
Aquaman talks to fishes.
If you give him a miracle exemption
from the laws of nature
to account for the power,
this part is just perfectly fine.
When you think, there are
electrical currents in your brain.
And they're constantly changing direction,
stopping, starting, moving
from one neuron to another.
Any change in electrical current
creates an electromagnetic wave.
It's the basis of radio.
So you create electromagnetic waves
just by you thinking like that.
These are extremely weak
electromagnetic waves,
roughly a billion times
weaker than the radio waves
that are in the room with you right now.
We never think about the fact that
we're surrounded by radio waves,
unless we can't get a cellphone signal.
Aquaman has presumably
a special ability to be sensitive
to these very weak electromagnetic waves
when he thinks
and when he's communicating
with other species.
Seawater is a million
times more conductive
to electric fields than
regular deionized water.
So, he's in seawater,
which is a great conductive medium
for the electromagnetic waves.
The fishes have a special organ
to detect these electromagnetic waves.
Sharks in particular,
their organs are so sensitive
that you take a AA battery, 1 1/2 volts,
and you attach one wire
up in, say, Boston,
off in the Boston Harbor,
and the other wire off
the coast of Florida,
and the shark would be able
to detect that electric field.
Extremely sensitive.
Once you make the miracle exemption
that he has this ability,
I give Aquaman 10 out of 10.
[suspenseful music]
Superman's X-ray vision.
We can see when light
shines into our eyes,
either directly from a light
or reflected off of an object.
Kryptonians apparently can also see
by emitting light,
being both the source of
illumination and the detector.
He can apparently emit light
in both the high-energy part
of the spectrum, X-rays,
and the low-energy part of the spectrum,
infrared light, heat vision.
X-rays come,
the wavelength of an X-ray
is about the size of an atom,
and it gets scattered by
the electrons in an atom.
The more electrons, the
more the scattering.
Water has 10 electrons, H2O molecule.
The calcium in your
bones has 20 electrons.
So the bones, your skeleton,
are much more effective
at scattering X-rays
than the best of your tissues,
which is why your skeleton shows up
so starkly in an X-ray image.
They say X-ray vision
can't penetrate lead,
and it's true. Lead has 82 electrons,
which makes it a very
effective scatterer of X-rays.
But gold has 79 electrons.
It should be just as good a scatterer.
So, the images that we see
here for Clark's X-ray vision,
that, I'm giving a good grade to,
but it gets downgraded by being able
to actually create photons
of light from the eye
that get reflected back
and detected again.
So there I'm gonna have to downgrade him.
I'll give him maybe five out of 10.
[screaming]
You don't have to be crazy
to do that, but it helps.
So, she has some superpower
that enables her to create
these very high-intensity sound waves.
The sound waves are the same type of
propulsive force in an explosion.
Say, dynamite or something exploding.
People get knocked down, windows break,
buildings can be shattered
because of the air molecules
traveling so fast,
slamming into an object,
and it's the air molecules,
and they're doing it.
OK. That...[laughs]
That's gonna cost you some points.
Here she's hanging onto the motorcycle,
maintaining her balance.
I don't doubt that there
are skilled athletes
that can actually do this.
And then as she catches
up with the other car
and is holding onto it
and then moves relative to it,
well, if she's holding onto the car,
she's traveling at the
same speed as the car.
So her relative velocity
to the car is zero.
Then even when she moves a
little bit forward at all,
that only requires her
a small additional
relative velocity forward
to get to the front of the car.
Harley Quinn maintaining
perfect roller-skating form
during this explosion, not so good.
So I give this maybe a six out of 10.
Shazam: Your phone's charged.
Your phone's charged.
Freddy: Superpowers.
Shazam: And your phone's charged.
Well, you think you can do better?
Jim: Yep, and the phone blows up,
because phones are not supposed
to be charged up by lightning!
The batteries work by a chemical reaction.
Chemical A and chemical
B go to chemical C and D,
and they do it in such a way that
they build up electrical
charges on the terminals,
and then you can use
those electrical charges
to power your phone.
And once you've used up
all of the chemical A and B,
you can force the
reaction to run backwards,
and go backwards from
C to D back to A and B.
And that's recharging your battery.
Zapping it in this way
is not only not going
to recharge the battery,
but it's gonna fry
all of the microchips that
you have in the phone.
He's a nice boy, but I give
this only a two out of 10.